summertime is here and so is our
resident tech guru cnet's dan ackerman
he joins us right now with some gadgets
that can help you stay stay cool and
also save some money this summer so
what's going on what do you got for us
i'm hearing about this summer essential
break it down i think you need some dual
gear for summer what are we kind of what
are we trying to do we're trying to
travel maybe we're going to go camping
maybe we're going to go to park
somebody's phone is going to die
everyone should have a power bank with
them there's a million of these they're
all fine i like ones like this this is
the oim a solar power bank it has a
whole bunch of
extra features built in it's got solar
you can put your phone on it for
wireless charging but my favorite thing
is i will never buy a power bank that
does not have the cables built in
anymore lightning usbc and and micro usb
so if that's going to save somebody's uh
summer right there having one of this
with the cables built in that's the key
we can't help but notice this of course
i know we've all been waiting to talk
about the ninja creamy ice cream maker
it's called the ninja creamy listen i
don't name these things
but i tried an old-fashioned ice cream
maker a couple weeks ago i borrowed one
the big metal tub
well you get the metal tub you put it in
the freezer they have those too yeah
that's how you weigh 20. do you remember
cranking it do it
oh you have to hand
this guy flips it on its head because
you just does anybody in the studio
remember cranking ice cream i'm not dan
do you remember cranking you told me
about one where you put it in the soccer
ball and you kick it around
ice cream
okay thank you klaus
so vindicate metal thing you take a
little okay but you're going to talk
about that that looks like ben and
jerry's pine we put that in the freezer
yeah and then you take that out 24 hours
you put it in here you hit the button 90
seconds it mixes this up
i made this from a little bit of cream
cheese whole milk cream sugar and
vanilla extract and that's it five
ingredients
seriously seriously you did yeah this is
really good did you make it here we made
it here i made it at home i tried a
whole bunch of different types don't get
me wrong i had to experiment i like that
that's something i can do with your kids
um how much is it how much is it this is
220 bucks okay uh but i like that you
can do multiple you can fill up multiple
little tubs and ahead of time in the
freezer and then put them in and just
make them one right after the other and
if you want flavors you just if you want
some fruit okay okay so there's also a
cool device that can help those regular
old window ac units turn into smart
units i live in a new york apartment i
got those window ac units just like
everybody else so this guy here the
sensibo is a little sensor and it will
detect your window ac unit as long as it
has an ir remote control which any you
know recent one has and then you get an
app so you can turn it on you can turn
it off you can set it to turn off when
you leave the house geofencing you can
set schedules with it uh and one of the
models even has air quality and it'll
tell you like there's a lot of co2 in
the air there's a lot of vocs maybe you
should open a window it's like 90 bucks
and it's a real great way to retrofit
your window ac units without getting
more ones we're supposed to go to
thermostats but nate is a master griller
so i think what do you got yeah let me
tell you now he'll be the judge of
whether this is good or not dan i used
to have a little apartment on elizabeth
street with a little patio in the
backyard and i had my grill out there
summer winter the whole time i tried one
of these years ago this uh igrill mini
it was bigger back then it's a smart
thermometer you don't need a smart
thermometer but it's kind of fun
so you plug it into whatever you're
grilling it's got the little it's got
the little transmitter here obviously
you get an app on your phone and you
could monitor it very closely but it
just goes like green yellow orange red
when you hit red what scissors you're
going to talk about oh this this is my
other back up for grilling because again
my little patio grill was in the alley
between buildings it was kind of dark so
i wish i had
a lot of people grill at night yeah yeah
right i grilled at night i grilled in
the wine now that seems good yeah all
right so what about uh cena in in this
cool new feature the cnet shopping i got
to tell you when i tell people to shop
for gadgets i think comparison shopping
is the most important thing you know
find the right price so we have a
browser extension it's called t-nut
shopping and it does all that price
comparison for you because i like to
tell you what to buy but then you've got
to find out where to buy it and get the
best price on it good job
dan thank you so much good to see you
again what a beautiful beard